vous aimeriez vous appeler salade de
fruits c'est un joli nom n'est-ce pas
mais écoutez plutôt ce qu'and dit
[Musique]
Bourville ta mère t'a donné comme prénom
salade de fruits oh quel joli
nom au nom de tes ancêtres havaïens il
faut reconnaître que tu le portes
bien salade de fruits jolie jolie jolie
tu plais à mon père tu plais à ma mère
salade de fruits jolie jolie jolie un
jour ou l'autre il faudra bien qu'on
nous
Marie
pendu dans ma paillote au bord de l'eau
il y a des ananas il y a des noix de
coco j'en ai déjà goûté je n'en veux
plus le fruit de ta bouche serait le
bienvenu salade de fruits joli joli
jolie tu plais à mon père tu plais à mer
salade de fruits jolie jolie jolie un
jour ou l'autre il faudra bien qu'on
nous
Marie je plongerai tout nu dans l'océan
pour te ramener des poissons
d'argent avec des coquillages lumineux
oui mais en est é change tu sais ce que
je
veux salade de fruits j joli jolie tu
plais à mon père tu plais à ma mère
salade de fruits joli joli joli un jour
ou l'autre il faudra bien qu'on nous
[Musique]
Marie on a donné chacun de tout son cœur
ce qu'il y avait en nous de
meilleurs au fond de ma paillote au bord
de l'eau ce panier qui bouge c'est un
petit
berceau salade de fruits jolie jolie
jolie tu plais à ton père tu plais à ta
mère salade de fruits joli joli joli
c'est toi le fruit de nos amours
bonjour
[Musique]
Petit depuis plusieurs semaines une
chanson se trouve en tête du marathon de
la chanson française l'émission
Dominique